I was on John from Bulldog mindsets
livestream yesterday and it was funny
talking about unicorns right because you
know as you know I'm role as a godfather
of the red pill and I'm I'm officially
stating at this moment here on
entrepreneurs and cars rule zero I am
The Godfather of the black pill because
I own every single one of those dorks
one of these guys calls himself face an
LMS right another guy who hides his face
complete dork on the internet and I said
to him cuz he all he wants to do is cry
about how he can't get girls he can't
get girls blah blah blah I'm ugly when
weighing wet right whatever I said okay
buddy you're so smart you're so woke you
got everything figured out you you you
clearly you're you're so red pill it's
gone black I was like tell me what do
you want from a girl and he's like well
I want a relationship and I want love
and I was like right there right there
you outed yourself cuz no the Box gone
here none of it when do we all that
around slaughter gravel to your voice
when it way when we all say like that we
we want love like love is a fool's or
solely yeah I wanted Jack you lations
that's let's be honest the captain I
want and I like a woman that is
affectionate and helps me in life that
assists me like today went to the to the
Mossad to the the the hot springs with
Miss MLD I only had a big Bill's on me I
had no hundred yen coins and I was like
Dan you know I was thinking to myself
how am I gonna figure this out I'm
walking upstairs miss MLD she's like hey
you're gonna go to the massage chair
right she's like do you have do you have
hundred yen coins we should get you some
I didn't even have to ask her
I've been dating her for over three
years now right and that kind of thing
right there that's what I like that's
the that's the affection because it it
assists me in my goals that's what you
should be looking for men you should be
out there looking for women that are
assisting you in building your
goals and your dreams I constantly tell
miss MLD all the time said listen if it
ever comes down to me choose in my
business and you I said
nine to ten out of ten I'm choosing the
business I was like I love you whatever
you want what you're a nice person
you're great you've helped me out but
you're replaceable because I'm number
one my show my my life this is the hot
dude life this is the hot dude show
starring me filmed by me directed by me
so like if you're not on board with it
you got to go but the thing is we're
these guys looking for these unicorns
they make women and love the center of
their life and this is what Jon for
bulldog mindset was saying quite
honestly the average guide that today I
mean which yeah you're you're older guy
you know the average guy today is a
complete [ __ ] hundred percent yeah and
a lot of things that like one of the
things that guys forget or for the most
part don't even know is that women fall
in love you when they're doing things
for you right you know you have to
competency test you got to give them
tasks to do it right I mean like a woman
that is useful to you in a long-term
basis well like my check goes to me
before I go in the show she's here right
now she goes I'll make you a sure Cody
de Boer and some lunch so when you're
done your show cuz she knows that I'm
fasting and I'm [ __ ] starving she's
like I'll feed you so when I'm done the
show I'm gonna go yet I don't make
myself lunch like that's what a good
woman in a long-term relationship will
do for a man is they will complement his
life and add value to it you know most
of them just won't even go that far